You have spent most of your adult life living alone as a single woman in different cities. And I want you to take me through that journey, what it has looked like for you, did it get easier or harder with age, with time?
Was it different renting alone as a 19-year-old single woman perhaps, you know, as opposed to maybe a 25-year-old? And did you find that the experience differed significantly depending on which city you were in?
So I I left home very early when I was in sixth class first and then from seventh class my parents had allowed me to travel and look for my own logistics on my own. So
I had, you know, sort of figured out how sometimes you have to be persuasive and assertive with people because I mean you're all not going to be you're not going to be taken seriously in that sense especially for when it's about your own convenience and your own safety, right?
But then, when I moved to Delhi in 2020 to rent alone.
No, I mean 2016 when I came here for college, at that time only the renting thing started because hostels were not sufficient. So, I rented this place with this girl and she
We were the three of us, okay? One girl was two years senior. We saw that there was always this they felt like, okay, these are children who are living away from girls, living away from their families. We have to be their parent in that sense. Which was quite bizarre because we were not
I mean, we were adults, and there were some things that were like, first, in the, when we moved in that house, the first conversation that my aunt had with the landlord was that we don't want her to face this, like, curfew timing and things.
That's why we have not put her in certain places, so if you tell us if there is that issue with you, then we will look somewhere else because first year
They are children, they will have fun, roam around, and wander.
She was like, my aunt was at the time 32, she understood, I mean she understands. So she had this conversation with this girl and that landlord's daughter was also quite young. She was 28, 29. She was like, yeah yeah that's not, I mean what is ours, we don't even live there.
In the house, like they used to live in the house across the street. We...
Just give the rent on time and don't like don't make noise so that neighbors complain to us. This was the basic thing that she like tried to be cool, whatever. But then within six months we started facing problems like
She would always come and check at the end of the month, I mean, in lieu of taking rent and all. We used to send that on the phone itself, then I don't know why it would come. For inspection, where have you which furniture and this is what I have been hearing, who came.
To see you guys and who has a boyfriend and he comes, who does he come to meet, that sort of thing. So we didn't even even have to do anything to be called out by her, she would send messages, I know somebody came home. I'm just not, the thing is
I don't remember who was, which boy was coming home at the time. It just used to annoy me that why is it a problem to her at all. She was going to throw us out after one incident where a few boys came home to drop us after this HKV night crawl or something.
And obviously, I mean, some of us were drunk, and a lot of, like, three or four girls were there who weren't even living there. So, in the CDO's super group, whatever commotion that had caused. It just happened once, and she called my aunt, and this girl, my friend's mom.
Everybody she called, she's like, I'm going to throw these girls out because they're just not good girls, that sort of thing. Every other day there's a new guy. One, there was this thing happening, I mean, there were people coming in, but then she also extrapolated it to a point that we...
Couldn't even talk about this at home, like she had already talked about it.
Hmm
So we had to move, uh, our, like, we had to vacate that flat and look for a flat nearby very quickly, which was, we didn't think this would be possible, but then, you know, we were lucky to find one very nearby.
So we moved there and the same problem continued there. It was a much smaller place and this one time this landlord, the landlord at New Place had seen a car parked inside outside of the house.
And that was a car belonging to one of our female friends.
Hmm
But she just assumed that you guys are calling boys home.
And this one time there was this random
And this one time there was this random person smoking in front of the house and she just assumed that we know him. And I moved into my first independent place like when I had a job. When I was I came back from Chennai in 2020.
And I took this flat and I was talking to the landlord being like listen my brother is going to visit. Probably my male relatives are also all other male relatives might also come. My uncles and all of that. So instead of being like you are not supposed to like call me out on whoever.
Comes home and all. It's my house, I will come with whoever. I was just like my male family members are going to be here so I'm sure I hope you don't have an objection to that. They were fine with it, I mean yes yes brother etc. whoever it is, whoever wants to call, call them.
So, to be on the safe side, I also put my brother's name on the rent agreement. Felt like to be on the safer side, I had to do it. That, I mean, my brother was also going to come to stay for a few months, but then I also had a boyfriend at the time, I was thinking that when he comes. So
Just be like, this is my brother. Also, no one was going to come home and check. I was my I was a grown-up adult, I had my own thing going on, but then I was still worried if that happens, what will I do then. So I just asked my brother if
We can have both of our names on the rent agreement so that they know that a boy and a girl live here. Then like a new set of problems I started facing because it was like anything I wanted from the landlord to fix or anything.
She would just not listen to me, and then when I tried having my brother talk to her, it was all sorted. Then I was in Noida, I was living in Noida after that with with a boy, first of all, I have a male friend.
So we went around looking for houses, obviously you can expect that nobody wanted to.
Give us their home because they were like, are you married? Are you siblings? And we were none of that. So then we started lying that we are siblings, somewhere we lied that we are siblings, somewhere we lied that we are going to get married, that's everything.
So obviously, where we said that we are siblings, there they let us live together, and there was not really a problem.
I mean, it was only six months. And and I remember there was one time that I was I had to send one set of furniture to my Nani's place because it was in my house and I didn't need it. So she needed it. So when that small elephant-like transport happens, you know.
After getting that done, I sent it in that, and because of the security at the main gate, there was so much commotion that the whole
Society got involved. They made this whole thing about how this girl without any permission from her landlord is moving out and you know running away. Without paying the rent and all that. Yes, useless assumptions. I mean, I was at home. It was just like two things, one cloth hanger and one big table.
that I was sending to my aunt's place and they were like they are moving without permission. The form that is required to move from the society, they didn't take it and they are moving this furniture here and there. So my landlord was called landlord was not living in the city.
A landlord was called and he just like shouted at me that give houses to girls and all this happens, that's why I give houses to family members. You people shouldn't give houses to bachelors, you can't trust them. All of this thing happened. Then my mother had to call the landlord and explain to him.
That this is actually what's happening, I am still going to be living there. It's just the two things I had to move out of my house and I just did that. Basically, I feel that there is like a lot of trust deficit, especially if you are not married.
Especially
So, I have experienced this a lot with the landlords. And you know, one time I was living with this girl in Noida only. Our landlord was like on the same floor but in a different apartment, and she was very sweet and all.
But that benevolent thing, you know, once she came to our house with two pots of neem plants, saplings. Okay? And she's like, keep it on the balcony, you both will get married soon. And we were so...
We were a bit out by that and he's like and she's like no, I also have daughters and it would be good if they get married on time. The girl that I was living with was 29. So I was saying more for her that this is still
He still has time, what have you thought? Why is a landlord supposed to come in the house and ask about when are you getting married, what are you This kind of things makes people uncomfortable but I don't know. People are like we can ask only if you are unmarried anybody can ask.
About your plans and all. But then, this thing, we have to keep in mind that you don't live with your parents, we consider you like our own children, this thing. At this time, she was doing all this, but then one time when she when she had to sell the flat.
She didn't even give us a 15-day notice. At this time, all the care and we are just like your mom and dad, all this goes away. Then she was like, you are grown up, you earn and eat on your own. You can find a house in 15 days when we told her, 'Aunty, this is not possible.'
Where will we go now if you have to vacate us? At least give us a one-month notice. But then she was like, no, no, you can do it, talk to the broker etc., you are independent. I think I have had a really bad experience landlord-wise everywhere I go. This place that I am living in.
There is a whole load, okay. One day I was talking to this vegetable seller. I will start from there, who operates nearby. So I asked him if you have any number when I need to order vegetables, can you come to my house and deliver them?
And he like very quickly gave me his card. And then I said that I live in this street over there. I was about to tell you which building I live in. He's like, yes, you live in this building, right, on the top floor. You and a man live there. He knew about us. And
After a few days, I was already like getting anxious because of that how does the vegetable seller know about me. I mean, what does he keep watching or do these people talk among themselves. I mean, my safety is also like a pressure point for me, right? I mean, I am I am living in
area, this market area and on the third floor even the tiffin aunty that I hired, she would always be like, be careful, how are you just the two of you living and that sort of thing. A few days later, it happened that the main gate on the ground floor.
Is not actually a proper gate. So since I came here, I have asked for like it to be repaired. I have also pitched that I will also invest money, the first floor people and my landlord, if you all pull in.
We can definitely get the door fixed, at least get a proper lock in there.
Okay, but nobody has to answer, nobody wants to engage in that conversation at all.
Hmm.
But then, whenever we order and the delivery people, at the time of returning, they just keep the door open, then it is directly on us. That why do you order food? Why do you why do you have to do this? That why is the delivery person coming at night? Why do you even have to do this? Okay?
Another thing happened in May 2023 when there was a dustbin.
That caught fire on my floor outside in the staircase section, and for at least 15 to 20 minutes, I mean, it took some time for that fire to develop into a big, big scary thing, and there were at least
10 men on the staircase shouting.
Hmm
My name was being called out, but none of them had the thing to like put the fire out, you know.
Okay.
Like the fire was burning, it had become so high, the flame was so high that it was black marked up to the ceiling. And you know, I, I mean as soon as I saw this, everybody was shouting at me and you know, calling me names and all sorts of things. If a fire is burning, then why are you doing this, man?
Hmm.
Then I opened the door and I saw it instantly, I went to the washroom. Luckily there was a bucket, half bucket of water that I went and immediately poured on it. And these people were mad about that as well that they spread garbage all over the building. I mean these people...
Meaning, the habit of chastizing reaches a point where you don't even care about your own safety. Like the whole building would have caught fire and these people would have been like, this girl did it.
Hmm
These girls live here, they did it. After this fire incident, the first thing my landlord did was,
Yeah, after this.
When she got to know about it.
Yes
She took our keys to the terrace. She is like, I will not give it, you have set fire. As a punishment.
And you know, those keys that I had, thank God I had those keys because I could go up and open the terrace door so that whatever smoke had accumulated in the building could get out.
Otherwise it would have been trapped, you know. It could it took me one year and a half for her to give me back those terrace keys. I said I won't pay the rent for this month if I don't get the key for the roof.
When you look back to all of it, what do you think could have actually helped you in these moments, you know, could it, could it have been better legal knowledge, could it have been, you know, being part of a community?
Where you could call somebody to help or you know something else entirely. And what do you think needs to change for single women, you know, in your age group or younger than you who are who rent now and who will rent after you?
I think more than the legal thing and I mean, you know, I am I have people in the city. I've always had my grandmother lives here. If it was about calling people for help, I always had that. But then I don't want to do that, right?
The thing that I have seen is that no matter how much
Legal action you can bring in as long as these people stop seeing single women as, you know, something, either they think something very sinister, or they think like, what, what, like she is doing something wrong, living alone, so someone is coming to meet her, like this is like...
Immoral or that sort of thing. Or they treat like, you know.
Yes
That which is of an authority type, that no, no, we will care, care for you, we will get you this and you know.
Like this electrician who comes to my place sometimes, he is just like, you try, you tell someone else, all the plumbers and electricians in Delhi are fraud and they will see that you
I have seen.
What do you live here? So they will absolutely do that and leave, what do they call it, scam and leave. So you should call me only, I am the only one who is okay. That sort of thing. Here this kind of protectionist, I don't know, whatever that is. And
This kind of treatment, I mean, like I don't even have my own parents, I am not working here, I am not doing anything, I am running anything here, I am running a scam just because I have rented a house. Right now I am used to this behavior, right?
So, I am going to move out of this house in May or something.
But that's not because she is being a certain way with me, that's all I have learned to handle it by being like I am giving you the rent and I am not asking you for anything, all the repairs and all of that, you don't even pay me for those things. So you can't talk to me whichever way you feel like, okay?
I am moving from here to go to a bigger place, but until now what I have seen, every time I have moved out of the house, it has been because of either like my office location changed or the landlord is being horrible and it's like completely unlivable in that situation.